sur facebook ou ailleurs l'histoire le
court la désinformation a parfois la
couenne dure
peu importe la quantité dans lequel
journalistique qui en démontrent la
fausseté ainsi que le très difficile à
briser
une expression que j'adore jeff c'est
l'expression nouvelle on by qui décrit
donc ces nouvelles qui reviennent
cycliquement constamment même si plein
de journalistes comme toi et déboulonné
complètement ce qui se dit de nouveau
ça revient la ville quand tout comme un
zombie peu importe qu'on fait ça
continue à circuler même après des
années même après plusieurs fois que des
journalistes avaient démenti de
l'histoire et des choses qui sont un peu
un peu plus absurdes comme cette idée là
que c'est moi aussi 5samedi c'est la
première fois en cinq cents ans qui ça
arrive et ça porte chance dans ce sera
bientôt votre vos s'est jamais mêlée
pour ce buzz amis qui sont quand même un
peu plus dommageable que cette idée là
que les réfugiés reçoivent plus d'argent
que les années au canada ça à la base
c'était une lettre d'opinion qui avait
été envoyé au trône aux stars 2004 et
même quelques mois plus tard lambeaux
demand trône auster dit écoute on
n'aurait dû jamais publié cette
chronique le sans vérifier les chiffres
et donc ça a été démenti dès le départ
malgré ça on la revoit encore j'ai moi
même démenti deux fois cette histoire
est à peu près tous les médias au canada
dont des matisse
ça circule toujours parce que quelque
part ça sert les intérêts de quelqu'un
maintenant comment on fait comment ça se
fait que c'est si difficile de briser ce
cycle vicieux la de ces nouvelles jambes
qui revient tout le temps mais en fait
c'est que c'est en quelque sorte des
légendes urbaines donc j'ai parlé à des
folkloristes
[Musique]
et revoilà le phénomène des fausses
nouvelles comme une extension de ce les
humains ont toujours raconter des
histoires petites rêveries ou même poste
pour exprimer leur stress leur train de
leur part ce qui est important là dedans
pour les gens qui partagent des stores
est pas nécessairement les faits les
chiffres avancés les statistiques noël
c'est vraiment pour communiquer un
commentaire sur la société donc même
quand c'est faux les gens disent oui
mais ça représente quand même la réalité
parce que si ce que j'essaie d'exprimer
ya vraiment une histoire qui vient
incarné parfaitement surnommait non
c'est près de chez nous dit au québec et
ça concerne dorval la municipalité de
dorval dans l'ouest de montréal
oui donc une autre fausse nouvelle
coriace donc cette idée là que le maire
de dorval refusé de bannir le port des
cantines scolaires
même si des parents d'élèves musulmans
l'avait demandé à sa sortie depuis
plusieurs années c'est impossible
cette histoire là en fait parce que les
mavs au québec n'ont absolument aucun
droit de regard sur ce qui se passe dans
les écoles donc à la balle ça ne se peut
pas malgré ça j'ai compté au moins 400
milles partage de cette histoire là qui
concerne le maire de dorval qui est
quand même pour la plus grande ville du
québec non c'est sûr mais sa part doute
donc il ya un peu de vérité là-dedans
c'est vraiment vive emea anticipe donc
une ville dans le sud est de la france
le maire dans cette villa avait bel et
bien refuser de bannir la part des
cantines scolaires doivent envoyer une
lettre aux parents l'expliqué des
parents qui l'avait demandé me
l'expliquer pas pourquoi donc on disait
qu'il y avait certains qui avaient
demandé pour des raisons religieuses
d'autres pour des convictions
personnelles à voir le véganisme ou
autres convictions comme ça et le maire
avait dit non à écouter c'est le même
club pour tout le monde donc ça a été
repris par un bloc d'extrême droite en
france qui a écrit une lettre au maire
d'antibes pour le féliciter d'avoir tenu
tête aux musulmans est en cours de route
quelqu'un puisse être là tout simplement
changer le nom de la ville dans steam
pour dorval à thoiry le nom de la france
pour canada et c'était parti donc ça n'a
pas pris beaucoup d'efforts pour créer
la fausse nouvelle la plus populaire de
l'histoire du québec et est ce que je
sois intéressant là dedans c'est que la
personne qui a fait ça savait qu'elle
mentait on sait pas c'est qui qui a fait
ça mais la personne qui a pris cet
extrait qui le modifier pour changer une
histoire de la france c'est délibéré que
c'était fait des livres
vraiment dont ce n'était pas un accident
c'est super compliqué histoire qui va
circuler pendant des années ont rejoint
des centaines de milliers de gens et 4
après avoir démenti la nouvelle
la mérite de dorval reçoit encore une
quantité significative de courriels à ce
sujet hôtes en provenance du canada que
d'ailleurs dans le monde
sébastien gauthier responsable des
communications de la ville de dorval a
rapidement constaté que cette petite
municipalité ne pouvait pas faire grand
chose contre la puissance des réseaux
sociaux
quatre ans plus tard monsieur gautier on
est encore en train d'en parler
qu'est-ce qui circulent et qu'est-ce qui
a vu le maire on n'ait pas fait des
citoyens qui surtout lui ont laissé
savoir lui ont transféré la nouvelle qui
circulaient à son sujet on est des
médias qui nous ont appelés également
pour nous faire-part être au courant il
ya ceux qui circulent à ce sujet donc on
a vu la nouvelle qui était fausse bien
entendu donc on voulait rectifier les
rectifier les faits mais en même temps
on n'avait pas énormément de moyens
parce que vous aviez à l'époque que
moyen en 2015 on avait notre site
internet
et c'est à peu près tout votre page bas
de page produit twitter absolument pas
donc on a fait une déclaration publiée
sur notre site internet
rectifiant les choses mentionnant que
c'était une fausse nouvelle que le maire
n'avait pas agi dans ce dossier là on
était peut-être un peu naïve dans ce
sens qu on a cru que la nouvelle mouret
d'elle-même
puis c'est ce que vous pensiez oui on a
peut-être un peu sous-estimé le pouvoir
du web et des médias sociaux ont saisi
bon bah comme toute nouvelle ça va
s'estomper on n'entendait plus parler
on a fait des déclarations on devrait
être correct on exactement ce qui est
fou c'est qu'encore récemment encore
cette année où vous recevez du courrier
même parfois de l'extérieur du canada
énormément qu'est ce que les gens disent
encore à ce sujet sans trois
premièrement des gens qui au moins on la
lucidité nous poser la question est ce
que c'est vrai j'ai vu telle chose est
ce que c'est vrai veut le savoir il ya
l'autre portion qui nous disent on a vu
votre déclaration on sait maintenant que
c'est faux mais c'est dommage parce que
ont trouvé que c'était une bonne
position et l'autre qu'on reçoit aussi
particulièrement souvent c'est des gens
qui sont pas au courant qu'ils pensent
toujours que la nouvelle est vraie et
puis qu une nuisette félicitations le
maire c'est un héros a à travers le
monde parce qu'on a reçoit d'outre-mer
des états unis de l'ouest canadien des
gens qui disent ah bravo au maire à
ester debout je vous dirai pas une
semaine qui passe sans que moi je vois
rien passé sur notre revue de presse
est-ce que vous avez les outils
nécessaires pour faire face à ce genre
de
déçus les outils nous avec facebook par
exemple en les au flag et on est formés
mais c'est pas comme si c'était une
ligne puis tu appelles facebook va
écouter à pouvoir lever tout ça ou même
un courriel qu'on peut envoyer à
facebook directement
il ya sur ce qui se passe à dorval pour
vous passer le peigne fin dans ce qui se
passe sur facebook ça marche pas comme
ça donc nous on fait notre petit bout de
chemin
mais c'est peut-être une goutte dans
l'océan lorsqu'on fait pourquoi d'après
vous la ville de dorval vu comment dit
on de la scène fléchettes sur le mur
j'ai aucune idée n'y a pas eu quelque
chose qui est arrivé à dorval pour
verdir abbado veille on fait telle chose
avec les musulmans ou les tags et on va
on voit les cibles et non ce cessez
tuning pour nous c'est une question
qu'on n'a jamais été gardés répondre ça
fait parler c'est un sujet qui est chaud
on la voit avec la charte des valeurs et
tout ça là l'une des passions la voûte
peut-être pour ceux que ça meurt jamais